and today um for uh two members
who let me know last night they couldn't
um representative alessia are you all
set to go do you need anything before we
start
all i need is uh who is taking whom's
place
okay so representative hill is taking
johnson is taking representative smith's
place did you say johnson
okay
as chair of the children and family law
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the 2019 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to me electronically
this is an executive session on bills
referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in a
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electric calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules and rsa 191a
anyone who has a problem accessing a
meeting should call
271-3600
or email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call no
roll call attendance when each member
states they're present please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
so representative alexia will you um
call the role yes madam chair
children and family law committee march
representative belanger president in the
lob with representatives the wiki madam
vice chair
madam chair representative johnson and
representative litchfield
would you mind giving me the room number
please 201 and 203.
representative de simone
good morning i am here in room 201 203
with the aforementioned representatives
you're welcome thank you representative
grossman
good morning i am here in my studio and
i have two
thank you representative levay
i am here i am in my spare room alone
thank you representative
wiki i am here at the llb in room 2016.
thank you representative litchfield
yes hello i'm president i am in the llb
room as well
um 2013.
thank you representative long
representative quit treating now good
morning
madam chair representative rice
yes i'm here in the lobby 20123 with
colleagues
i'm sorry i believe i said
oh i'm gonna go back back to
representative hill
and i apologize not a problem uh
madam clerk this is representative hill
i am home
alone um in my office
thank you and again i apologize
representative johnson
representative wazir good morning
um clerk i am home with
four children three of them are doing
remote
they will appear in the screen
thank you representative yokela
i i am here i am home
thank you
it's representative of here i'm in
stratham in my home office
thank you and representative alicea
okay so okay so we're going to start off
our exact session with
house bill 60 representative de simone
do you have a motion
thank you madam chair i would like to
move uh
a motion of retain i'll second that
motion
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair
i just believe that this bill
could really use a little more um
deliberation uh to be sure that we get
great thank you does anybody else
have anything i don't see any hands
raised i do not can you guys hear me
okay okay i just want to make sure
okay so the motion is to retain house
bill 60.
representative alicia will you call the
role
representative vice chair december
yes representative yo keller
representative yo keller can you yes
thank you thank you representative wiki
yes representative belanger
yes representative hill
yes representative
litchfield yes
[Music]
representative long no
no representative
um so happy women's history month i vote
no
the chair votes yes
i apologize madam cheer okay
vote is eight yeses and seven
names so the motion should retain
portfolio 60
passes i will give you a minute
before we start hb 120
representative elsia thank you just let
me know when you're ready
representative neal keller do you have a
motion
yes i move ought to pass
sarah second second seconded by
representative yopela i
move uh amendment 0517h
zero five one seven h do you have that
representative alcea
zero five seven eight
seven h and may i ask police who made
the original motion representative
yopela
thank you would you like to
speak to the amendment representative
yopela
the amendment uh replaces the whole bill
it's what we talked about in the
committee
and so um i think it's the one that we
should adopt
thank you for any
further comments or questions regarding
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
call the rule
on adopting amendment 0517h
representative yokela yes
representative wiki yes
representative belanger yes
representative hill yes
representative johnson yes
the clerk representative alicea votes
yes
representative grossman yes
representative levay yes
representative wizard yes
representative petrino yes
the vote is 15 yeses zero nays
yes go ahead representative yopela okay
thank you
so this bill uh as we heard in
the testimony was filed in response to
the
united states inspector general report
in september 2018
and it is trying to tighten oversight
over use of
psychotropic medications and foster care
and i think that
is a laudable goal and uh i think
is uh all of the all of the stakeholders
have been addressed in
in this amendment and so i will support
would anyone else like to speak on house
bill 120
see no one um representative alessia
representative representative desimone
yes representative wiki
yes representative belanger
yes representative hill
yes
representative litchfield yes
uh the clerk representative alicea votes
yes
representative grossman yes
representative yes
representative wazir yes
representative petrino yes
the vote is 15 yay 0
chair please forgive me okay
without objection this will be placed on
the
[Music]
okay thank you very much representative
yotella do you have a motion
yes i move ought to pass
i'll second that seconded by
representative de simone
yes thank you i believe that uh
this bill was passed years ago
and is important that people have uh
especially pro se ligands have a time
uh enough to prepare based on the
evidence
um being submitted in their uh divorce
proceedings
and i do not believe that this conflicts
with
uh the judicial rules
in the court and actually just um
creates a floor which the uh
judicial discretion cannot go below
it it does not mandate uh
such a lower standard so
i am happy to support this bill
and look forward to seeing it pass thank
you
representative law thank you madam chair
um actually last term hospital 1103
the committee did itl this bill and
um hearing from the judiciary that uh
their rules are already in place uh
where
this could happen uh and i caution
uh the committee with respect to
micromanaging the uh judicial uh
the judicial system thank you
they say none i'll have the clerk call
representative desimone yes
representative yocala yes
representative wiki yes
representative lishfield yes
the clerk represented valley alexey
invokes no representative grossman
no representative
representative guava no
representative nope
madam chair representative rice
yes
and there will be a minority report
i believe representative all chiller
will you be writing a
minority report on this uh yes i am
thank you if i can just have them by
friday
okay and then when the clerk is ready we
will do
hb 142 so just let me know when you're
ready men clerk
okay just want to share the vote was
thank you
we love you representatives
i know it's okay um i just want to share
it
when um madam chair
yes and am i allowed to share
when um different persons vote
i start with another person and
sometimes i miss
the name above or add the name above
it happens don't worry
make sure everybody gets to vote
i'm ready
representative de simone do you have a
motion
i do madam chair i would uh move
ought to pass on house bill 142.
is there a second second
seconded by representative lewicki
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair i would
i will be brief house bill 42
house bill 142 came about
uh because our present statute is 20
plus
years old and it doesn't reflect the
changes in society
like same-gender marriages
and the serious issues with substance
abuse
this bill simply updates those laws
to take them into consideration during
yet another difficult time
is there any further discussion
i just wanted to mention that in the
courts right now the
case blaisdell is addressing this issue
right now
and there will be a finding from the
courts in regards to
um yes in addition to
what representative grossman has pointed
out that this is already working its way
through the courts
and we are just awaiting a decision um
line 14 doesn't make any
um doesn't clarify whether
the abuse of substances is concurrent
consecutive with other if there is if
there are two
two substances and that's a um
you know a side-by-side abuse it doesn't
say whether it's you know two years in a
row or
if it is somebody who is in and out of
trying to
um trying to
go through some sort of a recovery
program so it's just
very nebulous and it's um it's not very
specific
and i think it causes a lot of problems
in that lack of specificity
so um i i'm going to vote against this
because i don't
i think that i like the idea of it but i
don't think it's very specific and i
think it opens up
thank you very much is there any further
discussion
representative grossman i see your hand
is is it still
up or okay i just don't want to miss
anybody
all right so i will have the clerk
seeing no further discussion
i will have the clerk call the role on
hb
representative madame chair rice
yes representative yokoa
yes representatives lewicki
yes representative belanger yes
representative hill yes
representative johnson yes
representative long yeah uh no
yeah uh
the clerk representative alicea old snow
representative was here no
representative petrino no
and the vote is eight to seven
yes i'll write that okay thank you
could you please clarify who said i will
write that
i apologize that's representative
grossman
madam chair yes
um i don't think that we talked about
hb20 going on
uh consent can we can we move that to
consent honey yes we did
they said without objection it would go
hey when the clerk's ready we'll start
um hb
161.
i'm ready madam chair representative
yokela
uh thank you i move ought to pass
i'll second that seconded by
representative de simone
okay go ahead representative ocala
okay um i move amendment
madam clerk do you have that amendment
zero five four nine h correct
would you like to speak to the amendment
representative your fellow
yes thank you so there was it seemed to
be that there was some confusion
on whether or not um adjustments
can be made based on the uh
best interest of the child and so this
language just
adds this to the this section of law so
that
it makes it clear that the best interest
of the child can be
a reason um for modification
so that's it thank you
okay is there any further discussion
on the amendment represented
no representative yes
could you re i for some reason i don't
think i have this amendment
did it come in our email yes and i have
i have copies here too
um i'm sorry could you just read the
number of the amendment
zero five four nine is that it zero
five four nine h ah okay
i do have it thank you so sorry no
problem
hey uh so is there did you want to
speak about it or are we good
somebody else had a question i'm fine
thank you i'll lower my hand all right
um then um seeing no more discussion
i will have the clerk call the role on
adopting amendment zero five four nine h
representative yokela
yes representative luiki yes
representative hill yes
representative alicea yes representative
grossman
yes weizier
yes representative petrino
yes representative walt sheller
yes did you you said 15-0 correct
correct okay so now the motion is ought
to pass as amended
representative yokela yes so
i just wanted to recap that um this is
just trying to implement the
recommendations by
the study done on child support
i believe back in 2018 it raises the
self
reserve support to 120 percent
it um allows
for a shared parenting plan formula
and it changes the um child support
guidelines based on the percentage of
combined net income to better reflect
what is actually
um on the ground essentially
now so uh i hope that you will support
this bill thank you very much
representative long thank you madam
chair
um although a little more plaudible with
the uh
with the amendment um i i think we're
sending
a wrong message to parents that
co-parent
if you're not taking your child
overnight you're not co-parenting
and i i think that's wrong and i i and
with respect to the study the study
had a redo calculation so i'm not
convinced that
the calculations are what we need uh so
i'll be
voting no any further discussion
representative wiki thank you madam
chair we have an ongoing problem
and perhaps this is not the perfect bill
but we do need to help parents and
children now not
in the future so if we cast this then we
thank you madam chair my i appreciate
the amendment and i voted for the
amendment
um my my objection lies in lines eight
and nine
is that shared parenting where the is
with where the child
overnights 30 or more of the time
i think that's an enormous conflict
creator
and um is
i i don't i don't know where that came
from in the study
uh and i don't think that it's an
appropriate place
to um tell parents
that a 30 of their time
with their child while they're sleeping
overnight
is shared parenting and i think it's
going to cause
way more problems than any of the rest
of the formula
could possibly help so i do not support
this bill
thank you is there any further
discussion
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
role
representative de simone yes
ma'am chair representative rice yes
representative o'kelley yes
representative belanger yes
representative hill yes
representative alicea votes no
representative waziri no
representative petrino no
i'm sorry i'm sorry the vote is eight to
seven
okay thank you is there going to be a
minority report
okay when the clerk is ready we'll be on
i'm ready manager hey senator g
monday of emotion thank you madam chair
i do
i'd like to make a motion to retain
house bill 228
is that seconded i second it
seconded by representative yokela would
you like to speak to your person
thank you madam chair i would house bill
also speaks about um
child support
in relation to people or approximately
equal parenting time
considering the bill that we just
passed with an otp i would like to keep
house bill 228 in retention
to go over any of the nuances that
are necessary to make sure that the
children are taken into consideration
with every move that the law
makes thank you
is there any further discussion uh okay
so
representative at chiller i see i've
seen your hand up but i don't know if it
went
after i i forgot i didn't lower it from
the last bill so sorry
that's why i asked representative long
so this doesn't give me the warm and
fuzzy on the last bill we just voted on
if we need to retain
something to make sure that does all
right uh when we're talking about
co-parenting
um the children aren't involved it's
it's parents we're taking care of
parents with respect to calculation of
child support
the children aren't the children aren't
involved it's between the parents
uh it's between the parents on child
support and
uh uh co-parenting now i
absolutely uh i absolutely
feel that we should encourage
co-parenting which
this may do probably not at the best
case scenario
uh because i do believe there's going to
be conflict so retaining this bill
uh which is which is a different
calculation
uh and different requirements of the
last one we just voted on i
i don't believe is uh sends the right
message
thank you thank you is there any further
discussion
representative about shiller yeah
yes i actually did raise my hand this
time it's painting
um so i i um
i do not support this bill and
specifically
in line four into line five creating a
rebuttable presumption
where the parties have agreed there is
there's
if we are if there is a um if we're
reaching this point
um in a child support case there's no
rebuttable
presumption and also in line 12
it says if the lower income party were
to pay the higher income party that's a
hypothetical that
is so out of the realm
um the difference from the amounts shall
be the presumptive child support
so it's basically setting up the higher
earning parent
to um look for ways to minimize their
income
um and i think that that's a you know
because it happens
it happens now to codify that and to
create an
avenue for them to do that is um i think
unconscionable and we heard testimony
that this
um setting up for one parent
to look to be underemployed for a period
of time
um is something that happens now
and we certainly don't want to make it
permanent or encourage it so i
i think that we should just um itl this
bill
and come at it from a different angle
next year all together
thank you is there any further
discussion
none i'll have the clerk call the role
representative keller yes
representative wiki yes
representative belanger yes
representative hill yes
representative litchfield yes
representative alicea
no representative
no representative was here
no representative katrina
no representative allshield
no
thank you so we will
um move on we're gonna actually let's
take a five minute break
um i know i had a member who had to step
out for a second so let's just take a
five minute break we'll be back
at 10 18 on the dot
yes
i like when we were in ways and me to
[Music]
okay everyone come back it's 10 18.
here they are they're coming
representative and representative
altschiller are you there
yes i am here okay can you turn your
camera on for
just be sure you turn your camera on
when we vote please
okay well we're gonna go ahead and start
and if she's not back by the time you
vote then
[Music]
i'll be nice and well stop it for a
minute but
so up next is house bill 293
representative belanger uh yes madam
chair
i have uh i moved to otp with an
amendment
okay is that seconded right now it's
just ought to pass
is that seconded seconded by
representative
wiki representative belangia
would you like to introduce your
amendment uh yes madam chair
i'm sorry i'm just pulling it up right
now um
the amendment as discussed last i need
the amendment number oh i'm sorry
uh the amendment number is five nine
zero beach it five four nine
it's gotta be more numbers than that uh
2021-0590
okay would you like to speak to your uh
regarding the amendment
uh yes madam chair uh so uh thank you
madam chair uh so the amendment
just fixes some working as i introduced
it last week during
uh a committee hearing
so on line 11
and was suggested
to change if you change and
um on line 11 just speak to
your amendment not suggestions that were
made okay
okay so
the intent behind the bill is to make it
easier for families to go through the
adoption process
there are safeguards in place
that help protect the child for example
guardians of life
guarding the item rsa is 461 which
addresses those concerns
this bill helps families move forward
okay is there any further discussion
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
roll on amendment
representative d simone yes
representative o'calla
yes representative wiki
yes representative
belanger yes
representative johnson yes
no representative valley say it
no representative levake
no representative wazir
no representative petrino
no representative hartschiller
no thank you
page motion now is ought to pass as
representative long thank you madam
chair
um so my concern is
uh is with respect to the assessment
um i mean uh a gal
is is assigned
however if a gao requested assessment
that assessment wouldn't happen
if there was a previous one done in
three years my understanding is that
there's
um my understanding is that
assessments happen has life change you
know has
issues change um there's an assessment
done
nothing you know everything is fine
uh the child's been abused there's
another assessment done
uh so my recall though i i i mean this
would be more palatable
if it were for family adoptions i i
absolutely get that
um but i do have an assessment i i do
have an issue with
um you know waving assessments after you
know if there was one done in previous
three years
thank you thank you representative long
representative thank you
um so in this bill
all we're talking about is whether or
not the court
may waive the assessment it is not
required to waive the assessment
and so this is just giving the option to
the court
to say this is not required in this
instance and obviously
if the court believes that it's required
then it has
every um it's completely within its
power to require
such a assessment and so i
i will vote be voting for this bill
thank you very much
representative thank you madam chair um
i so the the concerns
here is not
where we're this this bill is specific
to
assessment um it's in the in line five
it says the court
may proceed to a hearing it doesn't say
the court has to
gives them does give them the option to
deny the waiver
and they would have to provide an
example as to why they they did
chose to not do that and then it gives
them either of the following
circumstances so either option
a or option b if an assessment has been
completed in the previous three years it
gives it there is an assessment that
already has been completed
so they are able to use that assessment
um
you know it's a little disheartening to
hear uh why this
this this obvious bill that helps
streamline the process
for families um is gonna come out um
not to pass excuse me it would not come
out consent but i'm to be
voting yes and i urge everyone to vote
yes
as these concerns are addressed in other
rsas
there any further discussion
yes i just want to clarify where my vote
is coming from
for the record is that when we were um
we were all about this and were very
enthusiastic about
making this change but during testimony
we heard that there was concern
uh from agencies that work with the
families
that the space and the amendment um line
eight
parents of the minor are deceased when a
parent um
when a family member self-places
that there may not have been a
um an assessment done on their home
or their appropriateness
and so adding you know
taking line 11 and adding the word
and instead of or was something that i
think we all thought was going to happen
so that we could get behind this so
while this is a really really great idea
that would streamline
were it written um in a way that the
agencies who actually have to do this
work
um could could work with and
i think we all would have been behind it
so um
i do appreciate the work done so far and
um just wish that we had been able to
take it over the finish line with those
very very minor changes but without that
i'm sorry i cannot
support
okay is there any further discussion
representative your hand is up
yes thank you i i definitely uh
understand that this is trying to just
uh
create more of a streamlined uh
situation um in the law and
that the the change that
representative elshiller just mentioned
would be
considered in the law and so i think
that
that change um should be its own bill
and we should have a discussion on
whether or not
that policy um addition to
uh adoptions and increasing barriers to
adoption
is the right choice and so that's why if
i would not have supported such an
amendment um
and so i i don't agree with uh
with the representative statement that
we would have all been in agreement if
that
if that change was made so thank you
very much
representative belanger uh thank you
madam chair so i just want to
draw attention to rsa 461-8
16 which pertains to guardian of items
um
there it outlines a huge and i'm not
going to read it because
i want to make this quick but it
outlines a huge
area where a guardian nut litem may
provide a report to the court
which could potentially have an impact
on an adoption a guardian at latime is
appointed
at every adoption so
this bill is strictly
for assessments it reduces it from three
years to two years
so even if we weren't if changing
this and we just were adding lines seven
through eight
and left line 11 at three years and
chose to add and
then it still would make it more
difficult for families which is not
currently in practice now
do you have more no
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
world
on octopass as amended for house bill
madam chair representative rice yes
yes
representative yes
hill yes
representative litchfield yes
representative valencia no
representative grossman
no representative razier
no
representative petrino no
eight to seven the otp
with the amendment passes adam's chair
no
representative what's your question
um i just wanted to verify the uh
amendment that was adopted i have uh
amendment 0590h
what you show yeah okay thank you that's
correct
representative wiki do you have a friend
yes madam chair i move
in expedia to legislate and i will
second that motion is there any
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair uh
i'm a veteran i understand the time
things that may be very difficult for
some veterans however
um they're disabled veterans um
are based upon their ability to take
care of their family and themselves not
just
the veteran himself and i appreciate
that the federal government has not been
generous to the people who have served
our country
however it is not our business
to be trying to say that some people
will not have to pay child support and
others will the past laws for everyone
and this law is for
uh will be for everyone and it is not
appropriate in my opinion
and i mean i'd just like to say that
the evidence that we received is
a problem that we're really having i
think some things
are being uh confused
as to what um you know we we do
but honestly this this bill
is not gonna fix anything
to be quite honest so is there any
further discussion
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
roll
representative december yes
madam chair yes senator wright
yes representative
yes representative behind you
yes representative hill
representative johnson yes
yes representative alexeia
representative levick yes
representative was here
representative katrina yes
representative paul schiller yes
15-0 itl passes
without objection this bill can be
representative hill could i just ask you
to
we keep getting some feedback from you
i'm not sure why
so just sorry i didn't mean to
okay so up next is
house bill 460 representative long did
you want to make a motion
would you like to speak to your motion
representative law i would thank you
madam chair
uh yeah this this um this study
is an effort with which to um
get information that we need during our
hearings on specific bills uh
has it as it relates to the uh circuit
court
um so retaining this i you know i
i i think we may be able to get an
agreement i know
about three terms ago there was a clerk
who was assigned to the committee and
we'd ask questions and they'd
they'd go do a random poll of 25 or 10
percent and give us that number
and it was it was just very helpful uh
so i think in retention we may be able
to work with mr head now
uh to see whether or not that can be
done so
um supporting the
role
madam chair representative rice
yes representative december
representative i'm sorry representative
bellinger
elandra yes philander i'm very sorry
representative hill yes
representative jackson yes
representative long
yes representative alicea
representative
yes
representative petrino yes
representative altschiller yes the vote
is fifteen to zero
when you're ready for um house bill 494
thank you all right so house bill 494
representative de simone
[Music]
thank you madam chair i would like to
move out to pass
on house bill 494
seconded by representative lewicki
would you like to speak to your motion
um house bill 494
protects important constitutional rights
it also fills a boy in the first part of
the statute of
rsa 458 16. with
such uh conditions and limitations as
the
house bill 494 does not interfere with
civil restraining orders in any way
um it also does not
interfere with domestic violence orders
because they represent
compelling government interests
and finally they are narrowly
tailored to protect victims from abuse
and there's no less restrictive way to
thank you representative simone for the
discussion
representative outsiller
thank you very much madam chair um
so but uh what we
heard during testimony is that the state
in under none of the
um rsas that we have now um that relate
to this bill there is um there is no
exception to the constitution and this
um and all rulings are subject to review
um and the supreme court can evaluate
and
can determine if there is a basis for
overturning
and that this bill specifically um
particularly on lines six and seven
uh is a a procedure that would be
um placed upon the court so basically
the legislature
the legislative branch telling the
judicial branch the procedures under
which they must
operate um and
how they must do that so
in the in the analysis it it puts
you put out that unless the court
determines there's no less restrictive
means
so that's that's actually the judge's
decision
to decide how restrictive
like the what the what the gradation of
restriction
should be um and
this would pull that away from their
their decision-making process um
[Music]
so and also you know while it
does carve out 173 b
sometimes people um settle their cases
within
family court in
lieu of not having to go through a
domestic violence order
or a criminal case um there are
you know this isn't this would
disempower victims from
being able to to access um and i i just
think that
has a fundamental misunderstanding about
um creating an exception to the
constitution that really isn't there
um so uh
for those reasons i would hope that we
would give the judicial
branch the latitude
to do their job um and not micromanage
thank you representative lewicki thank
you madam chair
um passing statutes is precisely what we
are here for we were elected to pass
statutes
and those statutes are uh basis of what
the court should do
uh giving the court free reign to
basically make up the law
thank you any further discussion
representative atchillar
speak again no sorry lower okay
all right okay seeing no further
discussion
representative yes
madam chair representative rice yes
representative joaquella yes
representative wiki yes
representative belanger yes
representative hill yes
representative litchfield yes
representative johnson yes
representative alicea no
representative grossman
sorry about that as i muted um the
answer is no
okay back to mute representative
no representative wazir
no representative petrino
no
the vote is 8-0
no okay
all right madam clark just let me know
when you're ready for the next go
i'm ready representative de simone
thank you madam chair i move out to pass
on house bill 495
second seconded by representative
lewicki
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair i shout
house bill 495 protects important
constitutional rights that the parties
have
it also applies to orders in and out of
the restraining order context
this bill fills a void that is
present currently in rsa 461-uppercase
a colon 10.
with such conditions and limitations as
this bill specifically exempts domestic
violence
orders because they represent compelling
government interests
the bill does not interfere with civil
and the bill protects first amendment
violations
of free speech in and outside
the restraining order context
for these reasons
i move the octopath motion
thank you representative desamond
no
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
call the roll
madam chair representative rice yes
yes representative
representative litchfield yes
representative johnson yes
representative alicea no
representative grossman no
representative no
representative was here no
representative katrina no
the voted eight seven
no
okay up next is hp 547
yes madam chair i move hb 547 and xp8 to
legislate
said seconded representative the wiki
second set
thank you to speak to your motion uh yes
well
i appreciate that families deserve uh
evidentiary hearing um
evidentiary hearing excuse me
this bill needs some work and
i think it's it's important that we make
sure that we put the best legislation
forward
further discussion representative
wiki uh if people have had a chance to
look at the uh
court document with the scheduling uh
and so forth
it's already there we don't need uh to
do this and
the provisions are already in the court
procedures
seeing none i'll have the clerk called
representative desamond yes
representative
yes representative ricky
yes representative
yes representative hill
yes representative litchfield
yes representative
representative long yes
representative alicea yes
representative grossman yes
representative representative levake
[Music]
yes representative petrygno
yes representative hostiller
yes
15-0 that projection will place it on
next is houseboat 548 when the clerk's
i'm ready man cheers okay representative
belanger
uh thank you madam chair um
i again move house bill 548 and expedite
it to legislate
um
is that seconded seconded by
representative
wiki thank you would you like to speak
to your motion
yes sorry manager i tend to get ahead of
you sorry okay
um while i agree that this is
important again this this one does need
some work
um it is the duty of the guardian of
lighting to be
uh unbiased and i feel like that would
bring this forward so
i would like to do this in an unbiased
way so thank you manager
role
madam chair representative rice yes
representative de simone yes
representative yokela yes
lucky representative belanger
yes representative hill
yes representative
litchfield
representative johnson
yes thank you representative long
yes representative alicea
yes representative grossman
yes representative
was here yes
representative petrino yes
representative hot sheller yes
the vote is 15-0
objection that both can be placed on the
the next bill will be um house bill 556
just let me know when you're ready
representative alessia
madam chair you did say that it could go
on the consent calendar correct
yes without objection thank you
i'm ready manager thank you
representative
um litchfield do you have a motion yes i
would like to make a motion to retain
house bill 556.
you said seconded second seconded by
representative belanger
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i would thank you uh just pleading
simply
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
call the role
on retaining house bill 556.
madam chair representative rice yes
representative yes
representative bellander
yes representative hill
yes representative litchfield
yes representative johnson
yes representative long
yes representative alexeia
yes representative grossman
yes representative
yes representative petrino
yes representative paul
all right so how's the five five six is
between
up next will be how 562 when the clerk
representative belanger do you have a
motion uh yes ma'am chair i move
to retain house bill 562 uh the prime
sponsor
wait a minute is that seconded
second seconded by representative
lewicki
representative bolanger would you like
to speak to your motion
again i apologize just getting ahead of
myself um
yes the prime sponsor asked us to retain
this bill she would like to go over it
with a fine tooth comb and fix it
scene none i'll have the clerk call the
role on retaining house bill 562.
yes representative
representative hill yes
representative johnson yes
[Music]
yes representative
alicea yes representative grossman
levite yes
representative wazir yes
yes thank you representative pot
schiller
562 is retained
next will be house bill 577 whenever the
[Music]
thank you representative d simone
thank you madam chair i move itl on
house bill 577
is that seconded seconded
by representative belanger would you
like to speak to your motion
yes madam chair madam chair it's very
simple
the complex court is no longer in
existence
thank you madam chair thanks
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
role
representative desimone yes
madam chair representative rice yes
representative
yes representative
belanger yes
representative wiki yes
representative litchfield yes
representative johnson yes
representative alicea yes
representative grossman yes
representative levay
yes
representative wesley yes
representative petrino yes
representative schiller yes
the vote is 15-0 without
objection let's go on a consent calendar
so first i want to thank you guys
we moved right along we got all our work
done i really appreciate it
um did you want to say that i will be
happy when we're all back together we
had a lot of split bills today
and normally you know we really work
hard to
come to agreement i just think it's
harder to do
when we're not all together so i'm
really hoping that by next term we can
all
you know come together and and and
really compromise
so that we all come out winning on top
you know what i mean
um so that is that is um
where i'm at you know i really do
appreciate all of you and i i really
like how we normally work together and i
feel like it's just been
difficult this time around so
um i i look forward you know to the
future when we can all be together
representative levesque do you have a
question
no i have a comment um i am uh
willing to work with the committee to
help make um
the raising the marriage age bill
more better giving any information that
i can i have a six inch binder and
plenty of organizations who are willing
to help us out
with making sure that this gets passed
because uh in the last
over the weekend there was 180 something
people who
really want this bill passed and i
really hope that we do get it passed
someday and i'm willing to work with the
committee
great thank you so um
really i you know i thank you guys and
i promise to work harder to keep the
alliance of communication open between
all of us
um i i just found it it was hard i felt
we were a little rushed
this time around but um going forward i
really look forward to us
really working together and building our
relationships
no thank you madam chair there's uh
there's no committee report
for retain correct no no
okay thank you all right
okay well i will now adjourn this
executive session
and i thank you all and majority of
minority reports will be to me by friday
afternoon
that's right thank you everybody
okay thanks so much bye
so we're emailing those report to you
madam chair yes please
to you okay all right thanks so much you
guys
have a great day enjoy the rest of the
day i heard it's pretty nice outside
and madame chair i'll be dropping a
packet off this afternoon